for every person there's a moment my
wife and I lost our home to a fire when
they discover that the world when the
second plane hit it changed me and
everything they hold dear they placed in
my arms my first son tornado on the
ground phone lines were down
can be taken away and that's why I'm a
prepper that's why I'm a prepper that's
why I'm a prepper
well some hope for the best
these three we have uninvited guests are
preparing when they're in the worm state
where you can eat them for the worst
first shoot the deer
they are doomsday preppers
about seven years ago my wife and I lost
our home to a fire
I watched
a lifetime of work go up in smoke
[Music]
we lost the home
and everything in it
including my wife's wedding rings
and I don't ever want to feel
that helpless again
and that's why I'm a prepper
I have enough food stock to last 20
people for three months I have a storage
tank four ponds and a nearby weld I have
an underground bunker to keep my family
safe for when disaster strikes I'm
prepping for a terrorist attack on our
electrical grid that will send our
society into chaos
evidence collected by the U.S Department
of Homeland Security suggests that cyber
attacks on the electric grid are
increasing both in frequency and
sophistication Roger believes a
catastrophic terrorist attack on our
electric grid is imminent
and could send our nation back 150 years
overnight
we're literally one successful Cyber
attack away from our worst shares an
entire country with no electricity with
no electricity gas pumps don't work
trucks that take groceries to your
grocery store don't travel and in three
days this nation will be in chaos
and when people cannot feed their
children they'll be killing their
neighbors to steal their food
handle and wait 30 minutes for the
lights to come back on it's going to be
a life-changing event for every man
woman and child in this country
and everything that we take for granted
will be gone
[Music]
the state of Texas leads the nation in
privately owned working farms and with
three generations of farming behind them
Roger and his wife Jenny live and work
on their family farm just one hour
outside of Dallas my day usually starts
off with feeding all the animals
immediately followed by water in the
garden and the orchard then
whatever time is left in my day is
working on my preps this is the one I
want to use from rabbit cages
to avoid Federal Regulations Texas is
the only state in the continental U.S
that has a completely self-contained
grid making it harder for the state to
rely on its neighbors if there is a
Cyber attack
Roger fears that when the power goes out
it will be chaos above ground so he's
planning to take his family below it I
would absolutely consider the the bunker
the biggest project in my life 14 and a
half inches tall 12 by 13 12 this way 13
this way now Roger constructed the
bunker out of two shipping containers
each measuring eight feet wide 45 feet
long and nine feet high take that end
unroll and over the past two years he
spent over 2500 hours making it livable
okay that that's the final bunk
completed cool my wife and I have four
children between us
and six grandchildren Felician her
husband Shane here
the bunks in the dining room Blake and
Sammy and the bunker we can sleep a
dozen at the present time Jane is
getting the top of the freezer
okay
we have survived a house fire and had to
start over with nothing so we have a
very real appreciation of what it is to
lose everything
and the need to be better prepared for
whatever Life deals us
home cooking
and storing a minimum of three days of
non-perishable food and water per person
for emergencies
Roger is stockpiling enough food in his
bunker to feed 24 people over the course
of three months
we plan three meals a day
kids get grouchy when they're hungry I
don't do what grouchy kids I'd rather
feed them
beans rice dehydrated potatoes all of
those items are in food buckets the food
safe buckets are all sealed with mylar
bags oxygen absorbers inside of them
they'll be stored underneath the floor
in addition to we have individual
bottled water
on my property we have beef
pork chicken rabbits and fish I do not
anticipate a shortage of protein
although efficient Roger believes that
housing rabbits underground could be a
major liability as their urine is
corrosive making them a hazard in an
enclosed steel bunker so he plans to
stock the Bunker's 26 cubic foot freezer
with over 400 pounds of butchered meat
from his farm I would consider the
bunker 60 completed
I served in the United States Marine
Corps for three years as a diesel
mechanic so I have a background in
maintaining equipment that we've
accumulated for the Preps
so we're developing a system to pull
fresh air into the bunker and filter it
oh so that's going to be sitting
yes the fan is going to sit on top of
this piece the air intake system is a
crucial step in the the planning of any
bunker that's looking pretty good
anytime you have a large number of
people in a small space you don't want
to be overcome with the carbon dioxide
that we exhale filter lays in here
so just like your house the fresh air
comes in passes through the filter so it
forces all of the air out the bottom
into the room okay
if there's a problem outside somebody
finds your bunker wants to smoke you out
we have caps right here available to
screw in
to immediately protect you from whatever
is coming in that pipe that's not fresh
air
it's in
very cool
now that we have air
been waiting all day for that
Roger's military experience has also
prepared him to always have a backup
plan every good bunker needs a back door
during the Vietnam war Viet Cong
soldiers built the coochie tunnel system
as Guerrilla fortifications U.S attempts
to destroy the tunnels took longer than
expected as the Vietcong were constantly
rebuilding and expanding and included
defensive features like trap doors the
camouflage for the Escape patch is just
as important as their intake and exhaust
you don't want any part of the bunker to
be discovered from above ground
if the front door is discovered and
somebody's trying to get in you need a
way out to go deal with that threat
other than through the front door
the thought of the doghouse being great
camouflage is once this is installed and
the ground is graded off at that level
the old dog house that's been chewed on
by the dog just looks like something
sitting out behind the building you
didn't do anything with it's hiding in
plain sight
all I need is a pistol in my hand when I
come up out of there
I believe it's important for all of the
family members to be introduced to the
bunker
and the experience in advance so that
when
the day comes everybody's familiar with
it and how it works hello there don't
give me a hug in the event of the
electrical grid going down the bunker
will be necessary simply to keep the
family safe the experience in the bunker
will be for 24 hours
included in this bug in drill will be my
wife and I and our daughters Felicia and
Melissa Melissa's two children
and Felicia's husband Shane and their
two children
and my granddaughter Sammy I see you
brought your camera yep
a bunker definitely be necessary someday
but probably not
for a few more Generations I think eight
nine ten
I hope there's still 10 of us when we
finish tomorrow at least he can count
I got 15 rounds on me how many you have
my grandpa he uh can be pretty scary
everybody ready
who do you think is gonna be the first
to go insane
probably you hey
this is last call before we shut the
door no takers
okay
are you scared
a little I'm a little worried
Roger Dugan fears that a terror Terror
Cyber attack on America's electrical
grid will leave his family to fend for
themselves so for the past two years
he's been building an underground bunker
that he believes will keep his family
safe from the chaos everybody ready
today they are going underground for 24
hours
okay this is last call before we shut
the door
we're gonna do is collect all the cell
phones the grid is down there is no
internet chain the entertainment to kids
grow up with these days may not be
available
somebody is outside
and the only way they find our bunkers
because they hear your cell phone
they're all turned off and put up we're
one step safer we want you to keep the
video camera so we know who tries to
escape
um just don't let me know I don't
anticipate any negative reaction to my
rules my children and grandchildren are
used to Grandpa's house Grandpa's rules
Grandpa's bunkers really not any
different for them all firearms goes in
the next box
we don't want 14 grouchy people armed in
here at the same time
thank you I'm betting Melissa's carrying
thank you dear
the firearms and phones are going under
my bed there won't be no getting them
back
situations glad you asked last door on
the right
I built a nice wall for privacy
take care of business
you pump the plunger on the left pull
the handle out down here
it rinses the ball
close it back up so it don't smell up
the entire bunker is that private enough
for you yeah it seems to seems private
it's a bunker
I'm not too sure about it it's a little
weird
not not like home any other good
question it's unanimous let's eat all
right if we're all living in the bunker
you can bet everybody has to have a job
and a real love snow how would we do
today
how is it guys excellent mother
I want to see to it that all of the
people around this table survive and not
just survive but also Thrive whatever
the conditions of the rest of the world
they're settling in well and pretty
comfortable
can't wait really hungry today
they're playing board games I'm tired
like how you liked everything
if I zip you up you stay in there better
okay good boy
comfy
it's amazing what you can get used to
I believe everybody will survive the
night some will be more tense than
others
[Music]
well everybody just climbed to the bed
so I'm gonna sign off for tonight
uh hopefully I survive tonight
it's about 20 after seven and everyone's
still sleeping just fine
foreign
[Music]
how are you liking it in the bunker
you survived the knife what do you think
your wife I missed my phone what about
you it's time how are you three liking
the bunker
what y'all cooking we're gonna have
pancakes this morning
being of the bunker is very
claustrophobic it's a small amount of
space with a lot of people so kicking it
pretty difficult
what's that I understand you're the
artistic person in the family you can
say that a doomsday scenario would be an
extremely stressful time and anything I
can do for the family to reduce that
stress I want to do we would like you to
paint grass or trees or something like
that so we can have one small piece of
normalcy here underground that sword I
was looking for
it feels a little bit like a hospital
here in the bunker everything is white I
picked this so it feels a little bit
more like home so what's it gonna have
in it
some trees
make it look like it's a view I'm
outside
it's like hour 14 in the bunker and
she's painting a mural so we all don't
go crazy from Cabin Fever yay
I'm gonna come back and check on this
later
running off a generator
girl yeah anytime that electrical
appliances are being used we have to
turn off all the lights other than the
ones that are necessary hey is anybody's
listening to me or exactly
that looks amazing
I think this will be very helpful to not
be overcome with the stress of the
situation
you guys having fun
what's the hardest part of this
uh I don't know being
cool
well nobody go anywhere do you know what
happened
the breakers are on down here
that means
either the generator ran out of gas
or we have uninvited guests
super gonna be okay
certainly hope so
you have a seat and relax
[Music]
you know what happened the breakers are
on down here
do you think we're gonna be okay
certainly hope so
you have a seat and relax
[Music]
he'll be back now let us know what
happened and take care of the situation
are you scared
a little
I'm a little worried he hasn't shown up
yet but I think positive
and not think the worst that's how we
keep go through things
none of your preps food and water Etc
are going to do you any good if somebody
kills you and takes them away from your
family
I don't believe there is a limit to what
I would do
to protect my family and I would have to
uh
pray for those who did not have the good
judgment to realize that ahead of time
yay
that's great no we need his puppet to
come back I'm sure he'll be back down as
soon as he can
okay just putting gas in the generator I
learned that would I should keep the
generator full of fuel not not just
mostly proud of you guys I felt like my
family handled themselves very well and
what seemed like a long absence to them
I'm sure everybody ready to leave yeah
yes no
amen amen
everybody is just kind of gonna flip out
soon because we're all electronic
addicts except for like two people
so
well I'm sleepy
everybody ready yeah
I thought you might be
[Music]
everybody survived 24 hours in the
bunker
I believe this family will pull together
in whatever scenario awaits us
[Music]
definitely live in the bunker because
it's like oh my God if you got go
outside you're gonna die what do you
share I'd probably stay in the entire
time
wouldn't even try getting out
well did anybody learn anything if
something happens I would grab anything
that I need and Hike it on over here
that's what the whole experience was for
for us to get a better idea of what we
can do better and we can do anything if
we stick together
cyber attacks are an ongoing threat and
I don't hold a lot of faith that that
our federal government is going to save
us from any disaster you have the wolf
that will be out there capitalizing and
and creating more chaos and you have the
shepherd who needs to take care of the
sheep I would like to believe that that
I would be the Shepherd in that
situation
I'm prepared to do whatever it takes for
as long as it takes to see to it my
family is taking care of
the experts Practical Preppers have
scored your preps in five categories of
20 points each
food
16 out of 20 points water 15 out of 20
points shelter 14 out of 20 points
security 15 out of 20 points
you're an underground bunker with proper
air filtration and sanitation will be an
asset in a disaster situation
15 out of 20 X Factor points overall if
you get a 75 out of 100 you have 14
months initial survival time
if you think my security is only a 15
come try to get in the front door of my
bunker
[Music]
cyber attacks on the United States are
at an all-time high however the
government and the electric utility
industry are both taking action to
advance the grid infrastructure and
reduce cyber security risks
Curtis is stockpiling resources like a
Pioneer there you go but he believes his
most effective prep will be his large
family
and to defend their settlement on
doomsday balance on that red Timber he's
turning them
into an army there you go man you got
him that time didn't you
yeah
foreign
[Music]
because of the Y2K scare that we that
was approaching people were talking
about how everything was going to happen
the grid was going to go down all this
stuff so we bought a generator we
stocked up on some canned food had some
water on hand had a few gallons of gas
and as the time approached
I realized that we really were not ready
for this because we didn't know what was
going to happen we had no idea what
could happen we was watching on TV that
this could happen or that could happen
that nobody knew what what the results
were going to be when this Y2K thing hit
but the thing it did make me realize at
that point was that we were not ready
and that's why I am a prepper my farm
with various animals will continuously
feed my family I make and use primitive
weapons to protect and provide for my
family
I have almost 60 family members who will
help each other survive during Doomsday
I'm prepping from when the earth reaches
its carrying capacity
carry capacity is a biological concept
that states that when a certain
population reaches a certain size
something is going to happen to cause
that population to crash there are just
billions of people on this planet
there's already problems in several
countries concerning famine and disease
there's already problems with food
shortages
once countries start figuring out that
their people aren't getting the food
that they need there's going to be more
where they're going to be tried to take
resources from other countries and this
is going to lead to even more of a
population decline you know we're
looking at a domino effect it's going to
be so multifaceted that it's just going
to sweep over this planet and who knows
how many is going to be left
foreign
Curtis lives on a 35-acre farm in
Missouri with his wife Kathy a couple
more eggs should be enough
even though he fears overpopulation he
has 10 children and 35 grandchildren
most of whom live no more than 30 miles
away let's get the eggs oh yeah there's
still a chicken on there in there
a retired environmental consultant
Curtis spends his days researching
ancient civilizations because he hopes
they will hold the key to his family's
survival Amanda can you come in here a
minute in primitive time does the bigger
family you had the stronger your clan
was I may need some help in Remembering
some of the names of the the grandkids
since we have 35 we got Trenton okay and
then Andy Taylor Badger and turtle
Grayson that's it how do you spell that
Curtis believes that one thing that
helped the ancient Maya Thrive was the
way they organized their households 12
13 14. so Curtis wants to develop a
similar plan 27 20. how do we come up
with 28 I thought we had 35.
I got another
but in order for all 60 family members
to bug out to his home Curtis wants to
make sure his property can sustain them
all right you guys ready huh so he has
carefully selected three types of
livestock with efficient land to
production ratio we raise rabbits which
are great for Preppers because they
don't take up a whole lot of room and
they reproduce prolifically so you have
a steady supply of meat takes care of
the bunnies we have chickens that we get
eggs from year after year after year
there we go we have goats that we race
for for meat and milk the animals on
Curtis's Farm have 15 Acres of grazing
land and consume more than two thousand
pounds of feed a year today he's adding
another source of protein that won't
require any pasture and he hopes will be
completely self-sustainable we have uh
two ponds here on the property to start
getting a sustainable population of fish
that we can Harvest from year after year
50 catfish and two and a half pounds of
minnows we'll just I'll start unloading
them in the buckets and we'll walk them
down to the pond okay
Curtis is trying to create a stable
ecosystem using three different species
of fish the bluegill will eat aquatic
insects while the catfish will eat the
minnows as well as any dead material
along the bottom of the park Curtis
believes this will give his family a
self-replenishing food supply all right
let's get these down to the pond and
then uh come back and get the minnows
and bring those down okay sounds good
Alex you're helping us yay
now we're just gonna put a few every
Pond is only so big so it can only hold
so many fish
put too many in there then they all end
up staying real small because there's
not enough for them to eat for an
initial investment of 175 dollars Curtis
hopes to have enough fish to feed his
entire family of 60 indefinitely there
you go put them in the other bucket
cakey's got her worm she's ready she's
ready to fish
[Music]
fear carrying capacity
from the cities in search of food take
one shot at the pig believing that guns
will be a thing of the past he's
prepping his family for unconventional
warfare
Curtis fears that the Earth's population
will reach its carrying capacity
resulting in catastrophic events that
will set the world back hundreds of
years
it's a while a typical family might
gather for Sunday dinners Curtis's
weekly family gatherings are defensive
training sessions
today Curtis's teaching his
four-year-old grandson Badger how to
build a deadly weapon that dates back to
prehistoric times
all right we need to go find ourselves a
nice stick that we can use to make
paddle out of okay so I could be a nice
nice Branch to use right here the
Atlanta is an ancient weapon used from
Australia to Central and South America
am I like that yeah and can be used to
launch a dart or spear over short
distances with greater force Curtis
believes that after the Earth reaches
its carrying capacity the systems for
producing and distributing ammunition
will quickly disappear so people will
have to rely on weapons they can make
themselves
all right we'll try it out yeah let's go
try it out and that hooks in the end of
your dark just like that
grab this one okay now with those two
fingers you hold the dart there you go
okay how do you stand
how do you stand there you go
there you go nice
we are in the process of making sure
that everybody has at least some
training with these primitive weapons uh
not only uh the men but the the women as
well and the children
we start our grandchildren off at about
two three years old on how to shoot a
primitive bow are you gonna balance on
the log
you can line it up straight there you go
get it lined up straight oh that was
close
oh I almost got it you pull it back pull
it back until your hand gets right here
by your mouth just like that
[Music]
didn't you
you have to practice on a consistent
basis with these types of weapons it's
not like a gun it's not like you can
just pick it up line up the sights and
pull the trigger there's a lot more to
it than that and the only way to do that
is through practice
there you go good kill
we start off with basic training they
have to get their form and technique
down first and then they can work on
accuracy once you start getting your
accuracy down a little bit then we start
moving on to something a little more
difficult like what I call tactical bow
training Amanda I want you to balance on
that red Timber take one shot at the pig
shoot the little pig
oh one more
there you go good shot Curtis and his
family practice speed and precision
drones
pairs them to police training exercises
that reinforce basic gun handling for
quick response by replicating real life
scenarios
we're gonna try another one this one's
gonna be a little different drop the
marble in and before that marble hits
the can you run over to this stake kneel
and shoot
there you go good shot this shot you're
gonna lay down on the bench feet off the
ground and shoot the deer
nice
you have to be able to shoot fast that's
the main advantage we're gonna have with
these weapons is how fast we can get
those arrows out lying down lets
everybody get your arrows
when this planet has reached its
carrying capacity I know that our family
is going to be working together
because we have complete an absolute
trust in each of us to do the right
thing for the benefit of the family
because that's really what it all boils
down to is family
[Music]
the experts Practical Preppers have
scored your preps in five categories of
20 points each for a total possible
score of 100. food 10 out of 20 points
water 10 out of 20 points
shelter 14 out of 20 points security 12
out of 20 points
your primitive approach to preparedness
could go a long way in troubled times 17
out of 20 X Factor points
overall you get a 63 out of 100 you have
nine months initial survival time
the nine month survival time would
probably give us enough time that we can
start becoming a little more
self-sufficient
estimates on the carrying capacity of
the earth vary widely with many experts
concluding that it's impossible to
predict while researchers caution that
people need to make sound decisions to
minimize the impact of a growing
population many are optimistic that
technological advances and an eventual
population stabilization will overcome
the challenges of carrying capacity
every inch of Carissa baca's property is
used for prepping for a new Great
Depression and she believes she and her
pets will have to pay the price for
survival
I was a city girl work in a great
corporate job and I had beautiful things
and then the economy crashed I was laid
off along with a lot of my friends and
family
after that I had to file for bankruptcy
and suffer through losing all of those
things along with my condo
I then moved in with my parents and that
made me realize how fragile this economy
is and that's why I'm a prepper
chickens and goats provide for us and
are a huge part of all of our preps our
easy access to mountain spring water and
this 8 500 gallon tank means we will not
go thirsty we planted a quarter acre
Garden which provides us with most of
our food we're preparing for the Next
Great Depression
Carissa and Marcelo believed that the
2008 financial crisis was just the
beginning of an economic downward spiral
that will leave Society in debt with no
way out sending the U.S into Second
Great Depression stores closing people
losing their houses food shortages
people ransacking each other's homes
violence a shortage of weapons to
protect yourself
to be chaos
[Music]
one hour outside of San Diego lies Campo
California three years ago Carissa and
her husband Marcelo moved here to begin
their prepping lifestyle
this is our mini house we have an entire
house in about 350 square feet
keep the little baby chickens that are
just newly hatched
start down there with the eggs in the
incubator
and then once they're about getting
ready to hatch then we move them up here
to another incubator and everything's
temperature controlled this is our
newest little guy he's about two days
old yeah little guy you're just in an
egg huh he's waiting for the rest of his
brothers to come out too
I have about
41 chickens here and we should be
getting around 50 to 75 in the next
couple of months an economic class
happens we can sell them and trade them
for things that we need we grow
mealworms and the chickens eat them
they're a renewable source right now
they're in their Beetle State these
beetles lay eggs they become worms the
whole cycle just starts again when
they're in the worm state where you can
eat them and feed them to the chickens
it's good nutrients so we'll keep them
in here until they reproduce and then we
get more worms researchers have
estimated that meal worms are 25 protein
more than beef chicken
pork so while Carissa is growing the
meal worms as a renewable food source
for her chickens she also produces
enough to sustain her and Marcelo I'll
eat them toast them up put a little salt
on them
Carissa and Marcelo feel they have an
ample food supply but with 97 of Apparel
in the U.S Being imported they fear that
after an economic collapse clothing will
become unavailable so they are learning
how to make their own clothes from
scratch they're in economic collapse
we're going to have to know how to use
every part and every piece of our
animals and that includes their hair
known as shiangora dog hair was
historically used by the Navajo tribe to
produce textiles since before the
colonization of America good job good
job with dog hair said to be 80 warmer
than wool Carissa and Marcelo stockpile
both dog and goat hair in waterproof
containers all around their property we
have goat hair and dog hair and one of
the things to definitely learn is to
make your own clothing he's doing pretty
good so we're getting some local experts
out here today to help us see if we can
figure out how to spin animal hair what
were you guys interested in learning how
to spin uh goat hair and some dog hair
so the problem we're gonna run into with
the goat hair is that it's a really
smooth hairy fiber versus a wool in
fiber which has a lot of crimp in the
fiber strands that help lock it together
we use these These are called Hand cards
so we're going to have you take a little
bit of the goat hair yeah that's a
really good job so the goal of this is
to get all the fibers in One Direction
and it makes it a lot easier to spin if
they are all aligned do you think we can
use the dog hair to make it a little bit
better
we could try
[Music]
to make a roll log
so not so good now you're not work out
so well the goat hair and the dog hair
are too short to be able to be woven
together to make yarn we probably
suggest using like a longer staple
length of something I think you can try
human hair
[Music]
um I've never tried it but it's an
option we need the longer hair to put in
with the shorter hair
so I thought maybe we could use some
human hair
good job baby
once the human hair is carded locking
the clumps of fiber together a spindle
is used to twist the fibers into Yarn
yeah it works
we did try the human hair and it
actually worked and we made yarn about
six feet long so in the Second Great
Depression hits we'll be able to use our
animals and now we know we will be able
to use their hair as well it's a nice
color too yeah
I'm not going to go back to the city and
work at nine to five and rely on that
paycheck
ready to eat yep when an economic
collapse will happen it'd probably be
very bad at first the fact is I think it
is worth it to prepare
fresh eggs
I don't think we're paranoid
now I think we're just prepared
thank you
the experts Practical Preppers have
scored your preps in five categories of
20 points each
food 10 out of 20 points water 16 out of
20 points shelter 11 out of 20 points
security 4 out of 20 points implementing
self-sufficient techniques like raising
your own livestock and making yarn out
of animal hair is command
eight out of 20 X Factor points overall
you get a 49 out of 100 you have four
months initial survival time for
beginners so gotta start somewhere I
think we did pretty good for beginners
foreign although the 2008 economic
collapse proved to be the worst since
the Great Depression employment has
increased substantially and most
economists remain optimistic that the
chances of another Great Depression
occurring anytime soon are slam
[Music]